Helicopters will drop like a rock when the
engine shuts down.
In fact, you have a better chance at surviving
in a helicopter when the engine fails than
you do in an airplane.
Helicopters are designed specifically to allow
pilots to have a reasonable chance of landing
them safely in the case where the engine stops
working during flight, often with no damage
at all.
They accomplish this via autorotation of the
main rotor blades.
Further, when seeking a helicopter pilot’s
license, one has to practice landing using
this no-power technique.
When practicing, instead of actually shutting
the engine off completely though, they usually
just turn the engine down enough to disengage
it from the rotor.
This way, if the student encounters a problem
during a no-power landing, the helicopter
can be throttled back up to avoid an accident.
Given that this isn’t an option during actual
engine failure, it’s critical for helicopter
pilots to practice this until they have it
down pat.
A landing via autorotation is also sometimes
necessary if the rear rotor blades stop functioning
properly, no longer countering for the torque
of the main rotor blades, so the helicopter
will spin if the engine isn’t turned off.
Whether this happens and the pilot shuts off
the engine or in the case of actual engine
failure, once the engine drops below a certain
number of revolutions per minute, relative
to the rotor RPM rate, a special clutch mechanism,
called a freewheeling unit, disengages the
engine from the main rotor automatically.
This allows the main rotor to spin without
resistance from the engine.
Once the engine fails or otherwise is shut
off, the pilot must immediately lower the
pitch, reducing lift and drag, and the helicopter
will begin to descend.
If they don’t do this quick enough, allowing
the RPM of the main rotor to drop too far,
they’ll then lose control of the helicopter
and will likely not get it back.
When this happens, it may well drop like a
rock.
However, this isn’t typical because as soon
as the freewheeling unit disengages the engine,
the pilot is trained to respond appropriately
immediately.
Exactly what the correct glide angle is to
maintain optimal rotor RPM varies with different
helicopter designs, but this information is
readily available in the helicopter’s manual.
The glide angle also varies based on weather
conditions (wind, temperature, etc.), weight,
altitude, and airspeed, but in all cases a
correct glide angle has the effect of producing
an upward flow of air that will spin the main
rotor at some optimal RPM, storing kinetic
energy in the blades.
As the helicopter approaches the ground, the
pilot must then get rid of most of their forward
motion and slow the decent using the stored
up kinetic energy in the rotors.
If done perfectly, the landing will be quite
gentle.
They accomplish this by executing a flare,
pitching the nose up, at the right moment.
This will also have the effect of transferring
some of that energy from the forward momentum
into the main rotor, making it spin faster,
which will further allow for a smooth landing.
Because the flare will often need to be somewhat
dramatic, the tricky part here is making sure
that the rear of the helicopter doesn’t
hit the ground.
Ideally the pilot executes the flare (hopefully
stopping most all the forward motion and slowing
the decent to almost nothing), then levels
the nose out just before touchdown.
Autorotation may sound like a fairly complex
and difficult thing to do, but according to
one instructor I briefly chatted with about
this, it’s really not all that difficult
compared to a lot of other aspects of flying
a helicopter.
In fact, he stated that most students have
a lot more trouble when they first try things
like hovering, than they do when they first
try a no-power landing.
Granted, this is partially because students
don’t try autorotation landings until they
are near the end of their training, so they
are more skilled than when they first try
a lot of other maneuvers, but still.
It’s apparently not nearly as difficult
as it sounds and most of the problems students
have just stem from being nervous at descending
at a higher rate than normal.